a
desde el pasado 15 de enero el país se
encuentra en un confinamiento
generalizado en el que solo están
abiertos los supermercados las farmacias
y aquellos establecimientos que todavía
pueden seguir funcionando como 'take
away' las escuelas cerraron el pasado 22
de enero y hasta el momento no hay fecha
de reapertura esto pese a que han bajado
significativamente los índices de
contagio por kobe 19 a principios de año
se registraban entre 16.000 y 17.000
casos diarios en la última semana se han
reportado menos de 3.000 diarios sin
embargo no ha bajado la presión en los
hospitales y esta es una de las
principales razones por las cuales el
gobierno todavía no quiere hablar de
desconfía miento las unidades de
cuidados intensivos siguen trabajando
prácticamente el 90% de su capacidad las
fronteras se mantienen cerradas los
ciudadanos portugueses tienen
prohibición de salida del país bien sea
vía aérea marítima o terrestre a menos
que se trate de una medida humanitaria y
dentro del país está prohibida la
circulación entre municipios los fines
de semana son medidas que estarán
vigentes hasta el próximo primero de
marzo sin embargo ya el gobierno ha
advertido que este confinamiento podría
extenderse durante
todo el próximo mes
[Música]
las autoridades alemanas anunciaron la
semana pasada la extensión del
confinamiento general en el país hasta
el próximo 7 de marzo con dos
excepciones puntuales- las peluquerías
que podrán reabrir a partir del próximo
primero de marzo y los colegios cuya
apertura está en manos de los líderes
regionales del país dependiendo de la
situación específica en cada una de las
regiones la razón detrás de la extensión
del confinamiento son las nuevas
variantes del corona vivos que tienen
particularmente preocupadas las
autoridades pues consideran que tienen
el potencial de dañar los avances que ha
logrado alemania en las últimas semanas
los números han caído considerablemente
en alemania en lo que se refiere a
nuevas infecciones por corona virus ya
muertes por corona virus las variantes
también están detrás de otra decisión
tomada por las autoridades alemanas la
de imponer restricciones fronterizas con
austria y con república checa- dos
países muy afectados por las variantes
del coronavirus
[Música]
el gobierno peruano extendió la
cuarentena hasta el 28 de febrero en
lima y 32 provincias que fueron
declaradas en alerta extrema de contagio
y seguirá en confinamiento estricto con
toques de queda esto originó protestas
de diversos comerciantes en las regiones
de amazonas arequipa puno y tacna
quienes rechazan las restricciones y
toman las calles exigiendo que los dejen
trabajar para que sus negocios no
quiebren de otro lado el escándalo del
vacuna gate no sólo generó una nueva
crisis al país también provocó un
retraso en la distribución de las
700.000 dosis de vacunas que
corresponden a un segundo lote sino farc
esto encendió la indignación y
desesperación en médicos y enfermeras de
algunos hospitales que realizaron
protestas para reclamar las vacunas el
gobierno respondió movilizando aviones
del ejército para continuar con la
inmunización del personal sanitario las
autoridades han señalado que esta
primera etapa se vacunará cerca de
500.000 servidores de salud y en marzo
se espera contar con 2 millones de dosis
por mes que serán distribuidas por el
ejército y la empresa privada
[Música]